рішення щодо шингарі
новий український президент кажи що на
Сходу україною давина випадає його
точку зору
я б у край образного кристал термін
вина али зупинишся з правді ж хл
його на вихідних кіл-ві збувалося і
вибори у років домагайся станові ти видно
сни і припаяні не вчасно топ то роботи
так щуп зброї було за день на друк
підготовкою до вибору
зібрати з ти випадково як стала
серцем
он і в купе цим меншим зайняли
аеропорт донецького dp.ru ряд завдання удару
uuid за ціль свист потрібні спрею і
розрізання конфлікту на міжнародному
рівні та на 5 вищі шанси на накладення
промовив раніше в боці дикі вал можна
одразу метати ще чіпові на грубі ти
відлетиш коли я запускаю в середині
країни
просто врятував таріката потім через буваєте
поміняти сказати ще в рядах українців на
пузо стоїш і імпорт видно ви вирішите
дуже складні завдань нафту івашки
криза біля річки перебуваючи краї на тузи
що слід заруби те щоб стабілізувати
ситуацію на сході країни я обожнюю важливу
мені 1001 прибрані український президент
від риму в я закохавшись голосить у нього
немає шансів розстебнути і руку відразу
україни випадкової ціни можна його я ще
один показ м'якого неба спайки на вигляд не
може тут і поїхали там у необхідно ви
ситуації на сході стабілізувалася та
тут велика роль адже гра і карен листя
в Москві
чим чикішева ну та й одразу немає ще
підвищуючи результати українських виборів та
виставити готовності вести діалог та син
резидентом ти менше будруса протесті
підстанції від живуть і чого на неї
пам'ятникам і складаються волосок у тебе
так звана пробачать але тару як і його по
ви геть-чисто а ти можеш би його за краще
не сепаратисти в дол круглий столик
круглі steel сцени мирної конференції
розмова про припаяні йому вогню вирок
ще до виходу із ситуації
mode vs ти себе за за членами 2 рима
круглий steel білкова доучився я крісп
одягайся вигляді грамот і мораль та уми
буде думаючи лише про завдання і вам це дав
вчить гру маданськи істоті до загоню
національного діалогу
якому обидві руки кисть інституції встигли
їх поза заняттями для spylog
церкв рахунок національний діалог і б
зовсім малюковому парламенті
а завдання мирної конференції в ми вати
конфлікт із повстанцями пропустив
вигнуті не може хоч тому що сидять і
застиг журі донце астані чого хоче
повстанці
добре писати за цим слідством was very
buy online з їх медовий місяць